hey 42 here home to 7.2 billion people
planet Earth is a 5 billion year old
ball of iron oxygen silicon magnesium
and other trace elements hurtling
through space at 67,000 miles per hour
earth is a rather incredible place to be
but here's some of the most extreme
facts about the planet you live on earth
used to be purple from space land on the
Earth's surface appears mostly green but
millions of years ago it would have been
purple today's plants use a green
pigment called chlorophyll to harness
the sun's rays which gives them a green
appearance but research shows that
chlorophyll hasn't been around forever
in fact during the days of early life on
earth plants used to use a more
primitive molecule to harness the sun's
rays it was called retinol and it gave
off a violent you instead of a green one
meaning all photosynthesizing plans on
earth were at one point bright purple
but the dominant color on Earth's
surface
definitely isn't green when the first
astronauts that went into space looked
back at our planet they called it the
blue planet and that's hardly surprising
when you consider that Earth's surface
is 71% water with all that water you
would think we would know a bit more
about what's going on down there what
95% of us on the water world still
remains unexplored that's a remarkable
testament to how astonishingly vast the
oceans actually are only 3 percent of
water on earth is fresh water
the remaining 97% is salted water and
what's more of the
percent of fresh water 2% of it is
frozen in ice sheets and glaciers
meaning that less than 1% of water on
earth is fresh water which is found in
lakes rivers and underground the Earth's
core is as hot as the Sun the earth is
like an onion it is made up of three
separate layers the core the mantle and
the crust the core is made up of mostly
molten iron bubbling away at an
incredibly toasty 6100 degrees Celsius
making it is hot as the surface of the
Sun despite this intense heat the very
center of Earth's core remains solid
iron because of the immense amount of
pressure put upon the core from the
weight of the rest of the earth there is
a single mountain range that stretches
around the entire globe known as the
mid-ocean ridge system it's an
impressive range of underwater volcanoes
that spans the entirety of Earth's
oceans it was created from volcanic
eruptions of basaltic lava that occurs
between the Earth's tectonic plates at a
monstrous 60 thousand kilometers long
the mid-ocean ridge system is the
largest geological feature on earth the
closest contender above-ground is the
Andes mountain range in South America
which is a measly 7,200 kilometers in
comparison to this underwater giant
earth is the only planet in our solar
system that isn't named after a mythical
God earth isn't actually a sphere it's a
shape known as a geode this simply means
that the rounded ball bulges outwards at
the equator but what's even more
incredible is what causes earth to be
this shape instead of a perfectly formed
sphere Earth spins on its axis at a
thousand miles per hour
such a high rotational speed exerts an
incredible amount of centrifugal force
upon the equator pushing the earth and
water around the equator outward
slightly giving the earth somewhat of a
spare tire space is dirty every day our
planet is sprinkled with massive
quantities of interstellar fairy dust
100 tons of space dust and various other
debris
drifts down into our atmosphere and onto
the Earth's surface every day most of it
comes from other planets and comets and
finally in the interstellar scope earth
is tiny really tiny for example if you
compare it to the planet Jupiter earth
could fit inside Jupiter 1321 times and
if you think that's impressive nothing
will make you feel more like a
microscopic dot in the vast nothingness
of space than this fact earth could fit
inside the Sun 13 million time but don't
get downbeat earth is very special and
extremely unique earth is the only
planet we know of so far that has given
birth to life it has just the perfect
conditions the perfect temperature and
proximity to the Sun it has water and
the magnetic fields are protects us from
the sun's violent radiation as well as
many other important factors the chances
of all these factors coming together to
create a planet that can sustain life is
this or one in this number so the fact
that were even here to begin with is a
mathematical miracle and that folks is
what makes a so amazing thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2
you